whoa hello my name is Caleb Denby and
welcome back to game review today we're
gonna be going over a game between
Fabiano Cara Juana and Alexander Grisha
this game of course from the 2018
candidates shows once again why Fabiano
is one of the best in the world at
classical chess of course he won the
2018 candidates and went on to challenge
Magnus Carlsen for the world
championship title now this game started
with E 4 E 5 Knight f3 Knight f6 of
course entering the Petroff defence this
is one of the key openings that led
Fabiano to actually win the 2018
candidates with with this petrov of
course he wanted quite a few key games
in this opening Knight takes d5 is the
main line but in the game
Alexander Grichuk actually chose the
move d4 and this move immediately
challenges the center in a little bit of
a different manner than Knight takes e5
of course the downside to d4 is you did
not defend you're a pawn and Fabiano
simply captures now after D takes e5 we
see d5 from black and both sides now
have a pawn in the center Knight BD 2
comes challenging this Knight now this
Knight really can't stay on the e4
square for too long otherwise it is just
going to get captured so Knight takes D
2
Bishop takes D 2 Bishop e7 Bishop d3 now
c5 and C 3 and after knight c6 I will
pause here for just a moment and so we
kind of see in the key imbalance in the
game white is trying to claim that he
has a slight edge due to this advanced
epon on e5 meanwhile blacks pawns are a
little bit more compact a little bit
more connected and they are still
fighting for the center although white
is trying his best not to allow black to
gain similar space with the move d4 so
what we see here is black is gonna try
to take advantage of this ePHI pawn by
proving it's a little bit overextended
you can expect moves like Bishop g4
threatening to actually capture this
pawn
meanwhile white is gonna use this pawn
as a spatial edge to try and prove that
these bishops are gonna be just too
powerful
for black to handle in the game white
finished development with castles and
black brought this bishop out to g4 as
expected now Ricky one is a good
supporting move to support this pawn on
e5 and Queen d7 is blacks choice h3 from
white takes this bishop away so Bishop
h5 and now Bishop f4 you see the white
pieces all supporting this advanced epon
trying to keep this pawn as the just
annoying thorn in blacks side that he
can't get rid of fob you played Queen e6
black hitting the pawn now a 3 is
griffix choice and black gets castled
and so this is kind of the end of the
opening phase here and with this pawn on
e5 Grichuk does the classical idea of a
spatial advantage in the center one idea
with this spatial advantage is that it
cuts the black pieces in half and what
do I mean by this I mean it cuts this
bishop off from the Queen side of the
board they cuts this night off from the
Kings side of the board and with this
idea hopefully with the spaceship space
advantage you can cut these pieces off
and then focus your pieces on one side
of the board
so Greg tries to play on this Queen side
while the black pieces are a little bit
stuck over here on h5 in the meantime
though Fabi plays very naturally he
ignores this b4 pawn and plays h6 this
bishop actually drops back to g3 and now
we see the move b6 from Fabi
so Fabi just keeps everything nice and
solid and doesn't allow white to open
too many files on this Queen side and
take advantage of this a 5 pawn now
white plays a very interesting move and
that move is Knight to d4 so of course
if you take this night when we take your
bishop and if you take D 1 as was played
in the game simply Knight takes c6 f
take c6 and her a takes d1 and what has
white achieved with this maneuver well
he's gained the bishop pair
and how should you play against the
bishop pair is black you of course
shouldn't open diagonals you should not
open lines you should close things down
which is why we see the move c4 from
Bobby Bishop c2 and now B 5 and so what
Bobby has done is the ideal way to play
against these bishops this Bishop is on
some open diagonals but all of these
squares are covered by the white pawns
meanwhile this bishop isn't so
impressive staring at its own pawn on e5
so as always you want to close things
down against the bishops white plays a
for trying to break down this b5 pawn of
course we want to keep things closed
so simply a6 defending b5 now F 3 is
griffix choice trying to reroute this
bishop we see Bishop g5 from black very
natural move getting this bishop onto an
active square bishop f2 and now Bishop
f4 is putting annoying pressure on this
ePHI pawn Bishop c5 attacks this rook so
rook F to d8 and now Bishop d6 so we see
an interesting idea here or white's
bishop is posted up in black's camp and
black spaceship is posted up in the
white camp after Bishop g3 this row
comes to e2 and now g5 in the fact is
Fabiano has simply outplayed Alexander
grishnak so far in this game while why
does have the bishops this bishop
actually turns out to be a little bit of
a ghost
it's just looking at nothing on either
side of the board and so well we tend to
say that the good bishop is the bishop
on the opposite color as our pawns so in
this case these pawns in this bishop but
there's nothing for this bishop to do it
just looks at thin air on both sides of
the board meanwhile black's pieces make
a ton of sense they work together to
pressure this v5 pawn the game continued
with King f1 in now king f7 naturally
getting the Kings into the game Bishop
c7 from white attacks this rook simply
rook e8 and Grichuk already starts
repeating moves Fabi isn't happy with a
draw in this case though and I also want
to talk a little bit the game the
tournament situation in this case this
was the final round of the candidates
and with a draw Bobby would force a
playoff actually at the very least and
likely he would simply win outright
unless one of his chasers actually
managed to win in the last round but
Bobby was not happy with the draw he
played on trying to win the game after
Rick a 1 the Sura comes back to d8 we
see Bishop b1 and now rook d7 from Fabi
just getting these rooks a little bit
more mobile rook a3 was Critics Choice
and now the key breakthrough in the
position finally comes through of course
everybody at home sees it
what's the keep on break for black it is
d4 this is blacks idea to keep the game
going to get this pawn mobile on the C
file and get this Knight into the game a
takes b5 is played it takes b5 takes on
d4 Knight takes d4 and now black has a
powerful protected past C pawn say that
three times fast powerful protective
past C pawn rook e8 ooh now Knight comes
back to a 6 C 6 rather highlighting once
again that this pawn on e5 is weak
Bishop b4 from white but this finally
allows black to capture on e5 going up a
full pawn bishop takes c6 isn't it with
Rick takes d6 now black white regains
this pawn in an opposite colored Bishop
endgame but in this case it is nowhere
near a draw rook d1 check King e to rook
G 1 hits the e hits the G to pawn so
King III now rook b1 is hitting the beep
on Rick a7 check King f6 Bishop d7 favi
inserts this check King e2 now rook d8
black has defended all of his pieces for
the moment I mean there's no comfortable
way for white to actually guard this
pawn in fact white simply plays rook c2
trying to stop this pawn in its tracks
if you play something like rook b7 well
you're just gonna hit get hit with this
move c3 and already it's gonna be very
very difficult for you you can't bring
this King over to stop the pawn due to
this tactic so we just saw rook c2
instead but
the loser takes b4 and black is in fact
up a comfortable pawn bishop c6 this
pawn comes to c3 and after 87 we see
rook c8 and Fabi gain some more space on
this King side with age 5 and h4 and
after rook d1 king e5 getting the King
into the game we see a little bit of a
repetition and eventually though Fabi
does decide he wants to win the game
plays Bishop d2 and after Rick a6
Rick d8 Rick c6 rook b1 black is just
totally dominating the white pieces here
the syrup comes into D for the syrup
comes over to be four there are a ton of
ways to win this game but the way Fabi
did it is perfectly fine this King comes
in to f4 now and after king f2 we see
the rooks double on the first rank
creating checkmating threats rook f8
check the King drops back to e5 now
after Bishop d3 there comes back up to
be two once again not not quite the most
efficient way to win but perfectly fine
for Fabi
kingi 2 is met with rook e1 check King
f2 now Rick c1 forces this rook to trade
itself off if you take on c1 you get hit
with Bishop takes c1 check the King has
to come to the first rank and now you're
gonna get dominated with c2 and c1 to
follow so instead we saw rook takes B to
C takes b2 now Rick b8 tries to stop the
pawn from queening but bishop c3 Bishop
efore we give a check and after king you
to king f4 rook before E 5 defends the
Bishop rook b7 and King g3 is the move
that forced resignation from white no
way to keep all your pawns on the Kings
side as well as stop this beep on and so
with this game Bobby you know punched
his ticket to the world championship
match and 2018 by defeating Alexander
Grichuk and he did so with a win in the
final round very impressive stuff very
impressive stuff from Fabiano and i wish
him all the best in the 2020 candidates
i would love to see a big fobby magnus
rematch at this year's World
Championship well thank you very much
for joining me for this episode of
gaming
yeah my name is Caleb Denby and I'll see